Uh,
it does seem as if we are back to invasions again.
We end the course,
uh,
the way we began it except they're different invaders.
Um,
one thing that I'm sure professor frank will want you to get out of the vikings
course,
and not all of you are going to take that obviously.
So I will mention this as they did not have horned helmets.
Uh,
the horn helmet idea,
actually,
Roberta frank has researched where this totally inaccurate idea comes from and
um,
uh,
why it is a in eradicable.
But,
um,
if there's one thing you should come out of the second part of this course,
knowing it's that,
so we're discussing people from Scandinavia,
different parts of Scandinavia who had different destinations,
so different parts of Scandinavia,
Denmark,
Norway,
Sweden,
different destinations,
the Frankish empire of Charlemagne for which they'd bear some responsibility for
unraveling.
Uh,
Russia,
the British isles,
Iceland,
Greenland,
the new world.
Uh,
they certainly got around.
They're not always the same.
Um,
uh,
populations,
and they have different ambitions in different places.
Basically those ambitions can be divided into a rating,
trading and settling a,
these are not mutually exclusive.
A old,
usually they began by rating,
uh,
almost always if they were dealing with a place that had people thus obviously,
um,
uh,
Iceland when they came didn't have people at all.
So they came there as a explorers or settlers.
Uh,
the crucial changeover is in their attacks on the British isles and on the
Frankish empire,
they begin as Raiders.
That is as seaborne.
Um,
warriors who would plunder a opportunistic targets,
monasteries,
for example,
um,
and uh,
then leave with their,
uh,
spoils.
They also,
however,
were traders,
and I don't want to make too much of this as if it were a timeless statement,
but in the period we're dealing with rating and trading warrant all that far
apart.
Uh,
when the Vikings in the east,
mostly from Sweden,
we're dealing with the,
um,
califit in Baghdad or the Byzantine Empire,
they found these targets too well organized with two,
uh,
um,
overpowering a military presence,
uh,
to intimidate in the way that they were able to do with Britain and the Frankish
empire.
So here they were more traders.
Uh,
they brought,
um,
uh,
various products,
particularly slaves and for,
to the caliphate and to the Byzantine Empire.
And they came back with a lot of coins among other things.
Um,
uh,
80,000 coins from the caliphate have been found in Sweden alone.
So here they're traders,
settlers,
um,
they would,
uh,
eventually settle in the Frankish empire.
And in the,
um,
Anglo Saxon,
a kingdom of England,
uh,
they would settle in Ireland.
Indeed,
the city of Dublin was founded by the Vikings.
They would settle in Iceland completely.
That is the people who live in Iceland now are the descendants of mostly
Norwegian,
some Danish,
uh,
a settlers,
of the,
um,
10th and 11th centuries.
Uh,
they would even try to settle as far a field as Newfoundland.
there is,
uh,
a place in Newfoundland that a is unmistakably by the archeological evidence,
a Viking site.
Um,
uh,
this doesn't ultimately work,
so it is wrong to think of them exclusively as savage warriors as barbarians.
But then again,
we've seen that it's wrong to think of most of the invading peoples of the
period we were discussing as just totally savage.
Raiders of these are extremely skilled Raiders.
And as I've just gotten through saying there Raiders with several different
possible agendas.
They're very adaptive.
The question remains what made Scandinavia so powerful in the ninth and 10th
centuries,
especially since Scandinavia tends not to be,
um,
a,
a major actor in European politics of the two periods in which it is r this one,
basically the ninth,
10th,
11th centuries and the 17th century when the armies of Sweden under Gustavus
Adolphus terrorized,
um,
central Europe.
Uh,
the,
uh,
that,
effort was ultimately ended not in central Europe,
in eastern Europe,
by Russia and the Russians defeated the sweet sufficiently in the early 18th
century so that they basically never got themselves very heavily involved in
European politics.
Again,
um,
part of the answer of why Scandinavia,
why now is that we're dealing with another savage or certainly less civilized
population who erupt from their homeland and devastate a week,
but relatively rich society.
There is nothing very unusual about that.
We have seen it with the Roman empire.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
you can see it later with such a successful campaigns as those are the Mongols
in the 13th century.
So,
uh,
the other reason besides opportunity is tactics.
The Vikings were masters of the sea.
If you ever do go to Denmark,
Sweden or Norway,
you must go to the Viking museums there.
They're absolutely enthralling.
And you see these ships that seem unbelievably flimsy for the voyages that they
undertook on the other hand,
by reason of their small size and particularly shallow draft,
that is to say they're able to be stable without being so deep underneath the
ship.
You know,
having a Keogh underneath,
um,
that they can't sail up rivers.
They can both therefore go in the Atlantic,
uh,
and be stable enough to make the journey and go up rivers that are no more than
five or six feet deep at points like the sand,
uh,
in France or the law in France.
And so they could raid far inland with these ships and as masters of seas and
rivers,
they,
um,
could easily outrun the clumsy,
slow Carolingian armies.
They could rate a monastery,
check out another monastery the same afternoon,
uh Oh,
there's an army there.
Well,
we'll just get back in the ship and we'll go further down and then we'll,
we'll look for more tempting targets,
palaces,
towns,
uh,
monasteries.
They were not good at fortification.
If a place was fortified,
they tend to,
to pass it by.
They were not siege masters.
Uh,
their control therefore of the water is not dissimilar to the Arabs advantage.
and in the beginning of the Arab expansion that we talked about with regard to
the desert,
the desert functions the same way,
an environment that these people controlled in the sense that they could
maneuver easily in it and they're more civilized opponent with larger armies
could not.
The Persian and the Byzantine armies couldn't really go very far into the
desert.
They had supply line water problems.
They actually didn't know the desert all look the same to them.
Uh,
so this is the same or at least a similar advantage for the vikings.
The Vikings are different from other Raiders,
uh,
partly in their ability to construct governments not only to settle lands,
but to create governments ranging from the,
you know,
what advertises itself with some accuracy as the world's oldest democracy,
Iceland,
where,
you know,
tourists are still pointed out the place where the kind of parliament of all,
um,
uh,
citizens took place as early as I'm a thousand years ago.
And there are also the founders of Russia,
uh,
probably not to be advertised as the world's oldest democracy.
I was certainly not a country that's had a whole lot of experience with that
particular form of government.
But in fact,
the first Christian rulers of Russia,
uh,
the same of [inaudible] and his successors who were baptized and crowned by
Byzantine under Byzantine auspices,
we're a Scandinavian and the Scandinavian groups are called the roost.
They quickly lose their,
um,
Scandinavian language and identity,
but nevertheless,
that is the founding dynasty of the first Russian rulers.
So the Vikings,
uh,
have a fascinating culture and literature,
amazing sagas mostly preserved through their Icelandic versions.
Um,
uh,
very interesting art,
very interesting forms of decoration.
Uh,
and then these magnificent,
uh,
ships,
their major contribution to the history of Europe may be geopolitical in the
sense that they connect parts of the world that were otherwise minimally or not
at all connected.
So from Central Asia to Greenland,
they build various kinds of cultural and particularly commercial,
uh,
networks.
They also contribute to the destroying of the Carolingian Empire to the
destroying of what we were discussing before the vacation.
They're not the sole cause we talked about weaknesses within the Carolingian
Empire,
but certainly the viking invasions of devastated at during the ninth century,
uh,
did not at all help.
Where did this drive for expansion come from?
Uh,
besides opportunity.
Um,
and there's not a tremendous agreement on this point among scholars.
Uh,
overpopulation and land hunger are possible to this day.
These are not densely populated countries.
Uh,
and in the pre modern period they could not support,
uh,
anything but a very small population given the fact that most of the land is not
capable of being cultivated.
So you can get to a point of overpopulation,
pretty quick light,
um,
opportunities afforded by the weakness of others.
I mentioned us,
uh,
internal feuding and the creation of exiles.
Uh,
it's hard to separate legend from history,
but the legends about the founding of Iceland and Greenland in particular
involve people who were too rowdy for the vikings.
I pause on that cause it's a little hard to imagine what such a person would
have been like.
Uh,
nevertheless,
the Sagas,
uh,
tell us that various people were just too mean,
for,
um,
quiet,
civilized,
old Norway or even couldn't get their energies fulfilled by plundering the
Frankish empire and went off to Iceland and places like that.
Uh,
the climate conditions may have been favorable.
It may have been relatively warm.
Uh,
there's a lot of debate about the settlement of Greenland,
uh,
in this regard in particular.
Um,
we know that by the 12th and 13th centuries,
Greenland was becoming too cold for the Scandinavians,
uh,
and not for the Internet who were better adapted to real polar conditions.
Um,
but,
um,
you know,
this is something that is a of crucial importance and tracing the history of
climate,
uh,
and is a hotly debated,
but it certainly looks as if it gets colder in the 13th,
14th century,
particularly,
uh,
throughout,
um,
uh,
Europe and the Atlantic.
And,
uh,
probably warmer in the 10th and 11th centuries when this expansion is taking
place.
And then finally,
there's a cultive personal valor that is even stronger than that of a early
medieval Europe pain male cult of,
uh,
violent military bravery.
And the opportunity to demonstrate that a was a kind of competitive sport.
The Viking raids in England and the continent begin around 800.
Uh,
one of the first stunning events is the sac of the island monastery of Linda's
farm on the coast.
The eastern coast of northern England monastery of Lindisfarne was sacked by the
Vikings in seven 97.
Charlemagne was able to,
uh,
repulse these raids,
uhh,
and the English as well.
But the civil wars that we were talking about among the sons of Louis,
the pious,
um,
started to,
encourage the vikings and directly by the disunity of the Frankish empire,
the wasting a military resources on what was in effect,
a kind of civil war.
Um,
uh,
but also the vikings just get stronger and more ambitious because their raids on
relatively well organized Britain,
um,
uh,
start to reach their height in,
um,
the eight 30 days.
So you start having the abandonment of monasteries,
for example,
the abandonment of Linda's farm and the moving of its relics.
So the relics of Saint Cuthbert of York move around lot monks on the western
coast of France,
uh,
abandoned their monasteries and,
move their communities and relics further inland.
Um,
the vikings seem to jockey between emphasizing raids on the Frankish empire and
on England,
uh,
but basically they're doing both.
They start to spend the winter what's called overwintering in the late eight
thirties,
early eight forties.
And that's a sinister sign from the point of view of the English Irish and,
uh,
Frank's,
because that means that they're going from rating to some form of settling.
And if they can spend the winter and not just the classic rating season,
why not just stay permanently?
So,
um,
they start coming up the rivers.
They start plundering,
uh,
cities that are not sufficiently fortified.
Uh,
uh,
a monk in the eight sixties writes,
the number of ships grows every year.
You have the feeling of just this,
uh,
a complete takeover.
And now that's the monastic point of view.
The monasteries were ideal targets because they're rich,
isolated,
uh,
and um,
minimally fortified.
Uh,
but nevertheless,
the,
um,
uh,
the Carolinians have no fleet to match the viking ships.
The way to stop the vikings.
And it was only really implemented,
um,
uh,
in the late seventies and eighties.
The way to stop the vikings was with fortified bridges.
If you built a bridge to the vikings,
could not go past without fighting and fortified it sufficiently and had
sufficient numbers of troops,
you would stymie them.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this is eventually what happens in the late 19th century.
The Vikings are defeated at the gates of Paris in 1888.
Um,
and,
um,
uh,
eight,
85,
eight 86,
rather.
And they start accommodating with the,
uh,
European rulers.
That is to say they are given lands to settle,
uh,
and then,
um,
uh,
promised,
made to promise to stop rating.
And in effect,
they start to settle down towards the end of the ninth century,
uh,
beginning of the 10th century.
So that,
for example,
a treaty in nine 11 with the Frankish ruler,
West Frankish ruler,
the ruler,
we can start to call the king of France,
uh,
allows them to settle in north western France in a territory that henceforth was
called Norman Day.
Uh,
you know,
same in French,
uh,
Normandy.
The territory of the Northmen is one what they're usually referred to in the
sources rather than Vikings.
The territory of the Northmen.
So Normandy and nine 11 was a province settled by Vikings,
nominally loyal to the King of France.
The vikings very quickly lose their language.
By the time of the Duke of Normandy,
William the conqueror,
150 or so years later,
uh,
they are Norman.
They speak French.
Uh,
they are more French than anything else,
although,
uh,
a bit different.
Uh,
their shifts still look a bit like Viking ships.
If you know the bed by your tapestry,
which is this embroidery that shows the history of the Norman Conquest of
England,
uh,
their ships look very much like our image of Viking ships in England.
Uh,
the eight sixties are the zenith of their destruction.
They actually in effect partition England between a north,
uh,
um,
an eastern and a western part.
The eastern part becomes a territory called the Dane law.
Uh,
the,
uh,
place where the Danes have settled
and they are indirect effect on England is to force the Anglo Saxon Kingdoms to
unify.
So rather than the multiple kingdoms that we looked at at beads time,
Marsha,
east,
Anglia,
North Umbria,
we have the western kingdom formerly called Wessex,
which under King Alfred in the eight sixties to eight eighties,
becomes really,
uh,
the sole Anglo Saxon Kingdom of England and gradually defeats the Vikings
eventually,
uh,
kicking them out of the British isles altogether by about nine 30 or so.
So the conquests in the Frankish and English realms are not permanent in the
sense that,
uh,
there's minimal Scandinavian impact of a permanent sword on these places.
Uh,
you know,
they're not a lot of people speaking old Norse in either place in 1100,
but their impact is tremendous in terms of organizing these places,
creating networks,
founding cities like,
um,
a Dublin reorganizing kingdoms like Ireland,
uh,
creating Normandy and,
really,
uh,
kind of,
throwing the puzzle on the floor and reforming it
in the east and in the Atlantic.
Uh,
here you have to imagine or sort of visualized Scandinavia sitting on the top of
Europe.
Um,
the same effect that,
um,
uh,
encourages airlines to use polar routes as a shorter way to cross the globe also
allows the Scandinavians in effect to choose their targets.
Some of this is logical.
Norway is much easier,
much closer to the British isles than you might think.
It's sort of sits on top of them.
Um,
and Sweden is much closer to a of the east,
uh,
via the north than one would think.
But even Norway,
for example,
the modern kingdom of Norway has of border with Russia.
Uh,
it goes so far north.
and then it has this very little narrow,
um,
a piece of land that is only about 30 miles from the important Russian port of
Murmansk.
And all of these places are relatively warm given how far north they are because
of the Gulf stream.
So,
um,
just as,
uh,
you know,
London is surprisingly warm considering that it's on the same latitude as a
Newfoundland.
So these,
uh,
on northern parts of Scandinavia are the equivalent of,
you know,
polar,
a waste of northern Canada.
And yet they are,
um,
they're,
they're cold enough.
Problem with them is they're really dark,
so they're dark for months at a time,
but they're not all that coal from this vantage point.
Then the east would be attempting source of enterprise for vikings particularly,
but not exclusively from Scandinavia,
especially in the 10th century.
They would go via the Baltic Sea and the Gulf of Finland down the Russian
rivers,
like the Nipper nipper with a d two,
the,
uh,
um,
black say,
and the Volga to the Caspian Sea.
They used these rivers as ways of reaching territories of Byzantine and of a
California influence.
They,
uh,
traded
a when possible.
Okay.
Um,
a lot of our descriptions of the Vikings by outsiders are most accurate
descriptions are from Muslim travelers,
um,
who describe who these people are,
what their products are.
Um,
even though very little remains in this region to a test to the vikings,
the main evidence as we set our really coins taken back to Scandinavia,
they're base that is the Viking base in this eastern area was what would become
Kiev in modern Ukraine.
And Kiev would be the first Russian Scandinavian kingdom ruled by a czar.
They had ambitions to take over Constantinople,
uh,
a city that they called in sort of,
um,
tall can esque fashion,
Mikel Guard Miquel
guard meaning city Micole meaning powerful Mikel still in middle English and
Chaucer's English means,
uh,
um,
impressive,
uh,
powerful.
But the,
their attacks on Mikel Guard didn't work.
They the,
and eight,
60 and nine 41.
And we've seen that Constantinople was able to fight off a more impressive
enemies than this.
Uh,
they therefore were dealing with wealthy and established states.
Well organized states,
better organized than the Carolingian Empire,
the Anglo Saxon Kingdoms.
And so states that they were capable of,
um,
well the states that were capable of defeating them.
They,
uh,
therefore came to these areas,
Baghdad and Constantinople or controlled by Baghdad in Constantinople,
more his Raiders.
Uh,
I mean more as traders then as Raiders.
What did they bring to trade with?
They have certain classic products,
uh,
things from the North Sea like,
um,
Walrus,
ivory,
very highly prized,
um,
uh,
amber from the Baltic Sea.
Amber used in jewelry and medicine.
Uh,
uh,
a stone that's not really a stone,
a thing that's much lighter than it looks like a credited with various kinds of
mysterious or at least medicinal properties throughout the a Roman and as law
and formerly Roman and Islamic world,
um,
arrows and swords.
The West was very good at metalworking,
honey hunting falcons wax.
But as I said,
they're two great commodities were slaves and furs slaves be societies of the
Byzantine Empire and the Califit always wanted slaves.
They had plenty of unpleasant labor as well as domestic service shortages.
And so,
uh,
many of these slaves were Slavs Slavic populations rounded up by the vikings and
then sold in Constantinople or Baghdad.
First on the one hand,
first like sable Martin mink that abounded in the eastern Baltic regions and in
what's now a northern Russia were tremendously prized in a world in which
central heating was nonexistent.
And although we may not think of modern Istanbul as particularly cold,
uh,
it's quite cold and damp,
one can certainly understand the practical desire for furs for well off people
in the Byzantine Empire,
in the caliphate.
It may seem a little stranger,
Baghdad is more noted for unbearable heat.
Then cold.
Uh,
on the other hand,
the caliphate includes territory's like Afghanistan,
um,
eastern,
uh,
around,
and,
uh,
also keep in mind as is the case with Palm Beach and Miami Beach,
even as we speak now in late November,
that,
um,
uh,
for certain people,
the prestige of the firs,
uh,
transcends any need for practical warm.
Um,
so,
uh,
these are the two great products.
Yeah.
Um,
so they're plumbed or nerd,
plunderers and extortionists,
but they're fairly creative.
Plunderers and extortionists.
Uh,
they create,
uh,
a number of trading cities,
not only Kia of a further south,
but the great city of Novgorod
sort of between the Baltic and,
um,
the more modern city of Moscow.
These cities are fortified,
uh,
leading one to assume that they weren't just,
um,
free trade zones that,
uh,
other people rated them or that the vikings expected other people to try to
revenge themselves on their kind of rating and trading.
Okay.
So anyway,
as we've said before,
tre trading and plundering are not necessarily totally distinct.
Okay.
So,
um,
finally the West,
the vikings begin to explore the Atlantic mostly from Norway.
Yeah.
And beginning after the maximum period of rating of England starts to tail off
in the,
um,
in the eight sixties,
these lands were uninhabited,
Iceland or minimally inhabited inhabited Greenland.
Um,
they were very attractive for hunting and for pasturing
where the vikings found a fair density of people.
They tended not to stay.
This is their problem with Newfoundland.
They have a settlement in Newfoundland at a place whose modern name is a
somewhat confusingly called [inaudible] aux meadows,
sort of a French and English,
uh,
compound loss aux meadows in Newfoundland,
one of a number of,
certainly the most best known viking site.
But there were,
um,
uh,
native Americans who drove them out,
not necessarily because they were superior in,
um,
armament,
but,
uh,
it just wasn't really worth it to the Vikings,
to stay.
So they're staying in Newfoundland is relatively brief
in order to go from Norway to Iceland,
about 800 miles,
and it took anywhere between one week and one month.
Uh,
the island is not as cold as its name suggests it has glaciers.
But,
um,
you know,
in the part that don't have glaciers,
it's,
uh,
it's not,
it's not all that cold.
Um,
again,
the Gulf Stream,
uh,
most of it is uninhabitable,
but that's because of volcanic rock.
I don't know how many of you have been to Iceland,
but even the drive from the airport to Reykjavik is intimidating because it goes
through this stuff called [inaudible] and you know,
there are no trees and there's sort of no prospect of anything,
uh,
growing there.
But on the other hand,
there are plenty of,
uh,
nice coastal strips,
mild climate,
great pasture.
There are almost no trees now.
And there's a lot of debate about whether there were trees,
whether they just cut them down and they couldn't be a re,
uh,
re cultivated.
Uh,
but in fact,
this is a very hospitable place.
Rich pastures seem mammals everywhere until Iceland completely lost its mind in
the speculative atmosphere of the a decade proceeding 2008,
their main industry was cod fishing.
Uh,
they,
uh,
you know,
then went into banking in a way that just staggers the mind,
uh,
and,
have gotten back into cod fishing.
Uh,
uh,
my understanding is,
um,
but they had lots and lots of other things.
Um,
uh,
lots of seals which they killed for,
for a Walrus skin used for cable,
for ropes,
for ships,
a Walrus,
ivory,
another little creature called a nar whale that has a Tusk that looks like a
unit.
Weller was taken for being a Unicorn Tusk.
Uh,
there's one in the cloisters,
for example,
that some of you are going to see a on the 7th of December.
So the colonization of Iceland,
um,
uh,
begins,
in,
uh,
eight 70,
and by nine 30.
The island is basically full.
It's habitable land.
Again,
very,
very small percentage of the land area was,
was fully settled.
We know a lot more about Iceland than any other part of Scandinavia.
Uh,
because of the extraordinary,
uh,
quality and quantity of poetic stories.
Sagas um,
in which honor,
treasure and love of mayhem dominate.
These are very violent,
uh,
until a certain point were taken to be realistic portrayals of life in isolate.
And just as if say,
1950s in 1960s,
TV westerns were assumed to be a totally accurate portrayal of life everywhere
in the United States in the 19th century.
Uh,
so these are like Westerns,
a wonderful stories of male violence with a certain amount of exaggeration,
but nevertheless,
the reflection of customs,
ways of speaking and social values.
Towards the end of the 10th century,
Greenland was explored.
Um,
and they're the leadership of Eric,
the red one of these renegades so difficult and violent that he was exiled from
both Norway and Iceland.
Uh,
he is the one who seems to have dubbed this new territory.
Greenland,
um,
a pioneer of deceptive advertising.
I think it's fair to say because warm is,
it may have been in the 10th century.
Uh,
this doesn't seem,
this is like,
you know,
uh,
calling some housing development,
you know,
I'm warbling acres when in fact you've just bulldozed all the trees in order to,
to create the development.
So,
um,
the,
uh,
western coast of Greenland had rich pasture.
Uh,
the West is warmer than the east.
Um,
settlers came and beginning of 986,
uh,
there was even a bishopric established at a place called,
guard are other sort of a tall can ask name.
We don't know very many bishops who actually went to guard armed.
Most of them are old from Denmark,
uh,
and sort of basically sold their flock to get in touch with them if they needed
them.
I gave them their office hours and,
uh,
you know,
had a phone that took messages,
but,
um,
uh,
this,
settlement did not last.
Greenland was more or less abandoned by 1400,
and then would later be in modern times resettled.
Um,
uh,
but this time by Denmark.
And then finally,
Norwegians from Greenland,
a settled what's now Labrador and Newfoundland,
late 10th,
early 11th centuries,
they even wrote a saga called the Vin Lund Saga.
Um,
the inland map that's in the Beinecke library that purports to show both,
uh,
the,
Chinese Mongol Empire and,
uh,
the territory's of Finland in the new world is unfortunately a fake.
Um,
but,
uh,
as I said,
these archeological finds in Markland as the Vikings called Labrador or Finland
as they referred to,
uh,
Newfoundland are real.
They were settled about your 1000 and abandoned in 10 20.
Okay.
So here we are,
10 20 or the year 1000.
Uh,
and uh,
I know that you will be asking,
uh,
what has been accomplished since we began with two 84.
And is this a fair question?
Because at first glance,
it would seem as if we're still in a world of declining population,
uh,
a rural society,
very few urban centers,
uh,
a society of relatively little literacy,
relatively small amounts of commerce,
lots of violence,
lack of governmental order,
militarized society,
all developments that we have been tracing since,
uh,
the beginning.
The optimistic take on this is that beginning with the material covered in the
next course,
there's a very rapid ascent from 1000 to about 1300.
A tremendous growth of the European economy and a tremendous expansion of both
population,
uh,
artistic,
political,
intellectual creativity.
That is the central period of the Middle Ages.
The real mystery behind this,
the sort of historical problem is what explains the domination of Europe and the
second millennium,
80,
the first millennium,
most of which we've covered in this course.
Uh,
the dominant areas are the Mediterranean at the beginning,
which includes Europe,
but also includes North Africa,
Egypt,
the Middle East,
uh,
and modern Turkey.
And indeed those latter regions would out pace Europe properly speaking.
The first millennium is something of a catastrophe for Europe at least by
measurable statistics of a per capita GNP population,
population density,
urbanization,
uh,
um,
nature.
What then explains the domination of Europe after 1000.
Uh,
in some ways it's a slow process.
The first European colonies don't really get established until the aftermath of
Columbus's voyage in 1492.
Uh,
and then they get established incredibly rapidly and with surprisingly little
effort,
right?
Mexico and Peru,
these huge empires of the Aztecs,
Mayans and Incas fall to a few hundred Spanish troops and the Spanish and
Portuguese,
uh,
of between 1492 and 1520 are all over the world from Malacca in a modern
Malaysia to India,
to the Persian Gulf to Mexico.
Um,
and,
uh,
Peru,
well,
we don't have to explain that and that's for another time.
But suffice it to say that already in 10 95,
the European,
uh,
Christian population is capable of putting together an army to conquer Jerusalem
from Islam.
I seemingly impossible job,
uh,
and certainly one that required more than logistics and resources.
But also a certain kind of,
um,
uh,
if not fanaticism,
at least a real motivation,
religious motivation.
Uh,
but nevertheless it is a sign of a certain kind of European power that one would
not have thought in the year 1000,
uh,
was possible.
And the year 1000,
the smart money,
the,
um,
you know,
Brookings Institute think tank kind of Rand Corporation,
Bain Consulting,
you know,
all the smart people would have said,
don't put any money into Europe.
You've gotta be kidding.
Uh,
the coming regions are the same as,
uh,
over the last couple hundred years.
Maybe Byzantium you know,
a cautious by definitely the Islamic kingdoms,
even if the caliphate is having some problems.
Kwok Kala,
their successor states Fatimid in Egypt.
Awesome,
awesome.
This,
this is going to dominate the next millennium.
Uh,
our,
uh,
you know,
algorithms agree on this and um,
and,
uh,
all sorts of promising signs in eastern Europe with the creation of [inaudible]
younger hot shot a year,
um,
uh,
consultants would have identified that,
but Germany,
Italy,
France,
uh,
um,
the British isles,
uh,
certainly would have seemed discouraging yet.
There are some promising signs.
As it turns out,
the vikings are the last invaders.
The Vikings,
um,
coincide with invasions from the moggy,
ours
Magyars that's what they call themselves.
To this day,
they're known as the Hungarians to the outside world out of a confusion between
them and the huns.
Uh,
they actually have nothing to do with the huns,
uh,
but they were,
um,
quite frightening land based Raiders of the 10th century.
And there were also attacks by ships from Muslim north Africa against Europe,
what the sources referred to as Sarah's and pirates.
Um,
and they plunder Roman eight 43,
for example.
Uh,
so,
um,
Europe is certainly in the 10th century faced with yet another wave of
invasions.
And I think I warned you at the beginning of this course that it was basically
about,
uh,
invasions and heresies and that you do well if you just concentrated on those
things.
So we're heresy free at the moment,
but in the 10th century,
certainly how would we send patients guy as it happens there,
the last that western Europe would experience,
not eastern Europe because eastern Europe would be subject to the Mongols who
would,
for example,
score a tremendous victory over the armies of Poland,
uh,
armies over the Christian King of Hungary,
as well in the 13th century.
Um,
but this seems to be the end of invasions.
The beginning of a period of population increase,
better nutrition,
better harvests,
perhaps explicable to more settled conditions,
perhaps explainable by improved climate,
um,
perhaps just explainable by a human determination and enterprise.
The Christianization of Europe is one of the tremendous phenomena that
characterizes our period.
And while as a religious movement,
I have no investment in saying that Christianity is either an advantage or
disadvantage in terms of creating settled,
organized policies.
The Christianization of places like Scandinavia,
Iceland or Bohemia,
the modern Czech Republic,
more or less,
or Hungary or Russia,
all of which take place in the 10th or early 11th centuries.
All of these Christianization conversions bring these polities into a kind of
European cultural area,
political alliances,
trade networks.
So Christianization is as much a sign of civilization or at least have a kind of
economic development,
uh,
as a,
you know,
um,
a thing in itself.
Yeah.
So between 201,000,
what are the big differences?
Whether these are accomplishments or not is debatable.
Certainly the population has declined over an 800 year period.
The population of Europe is considerably less,
not only in towns like Rome,
which has gone from something on the order of over 500,000,
perhaps as much as a million to 30,000 maximum.
It is a much less Mediterranean centered world.
The sort of Geo politics have changed.
The Mediterranean has broken apart into Islamic Byzantine and Latin,
uh,
regions.
It is Christian,
most of it,
most of Europe,
part from,
uh,
Spain is Christian and this entails all sorts of cultural as well as religious
changes.
It is also less learned and the learning that there is is a monopoly of the
church.
There is less lay or secular learning than there was.
There are some continuity's.
However,
the dominant language of learning and administration remains in 1000 as it was
in 200 Latin.
Roman culture is still the ideal end still in effect,
the practice,
even though it may be adapted to things like churches,
but what has been called Romanesque or simply Roman architecture can move out of
the 11th and early 12th centuries Oh will indeed be based on Roman principles.
And as we saw with Charlemagne,
the idea of Rome,
the idea of the empire is extremely durable and although Charlemagne's empire is
dissolved in the course of the late 19th century,
it is at least partially revived in the 10th century under a new dynasty.
Oh,
who's first ruler is auto,
the first auto,
the great,
uh,
in nine 62,
he's crowned Roman in Rome by the pope.
His empire doesn't clue,
does not include the West.
So it's not France,
it's more Germany than anything else.
But this empire would endure until Napoleon,
uh,
until 1804.
In other words,
for,
uh,
something on the order of 850 years.
Yeah.
So to some extent,
um,
we are what we have accomplished as we've arrived at the point of the emergence
of something that can be called Europe,
other than a geographical term,
something that can be called Christendom.
Uh,
not using that in its triumphalist sense,
but simply as a kind of cultural description of a certain part of the world.
Um,
and we've reached the point where we can start to talk about the west,
this very funny term,
still used particularly in popular geopolitical,
uh,
tracks like the west and the rest of these kinds of,
statements of the West or the decline of the West.
We're at the point of the rise of the west and that's where I am going to leave
you with a thanks for your participation in this course.
Thanks for making this a wonderful semester for me.
I hope a lot of fun for you as well.
[inaudible].